[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette foire aux questions sur un
tract sciences où j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir pour la deuxième fois sur
cette chaîne dans troisième fois
d'ailleurs troisième fois sur cette
chaîne le docteur christophe hendrix
christophe bonjour donc christophe tu es
un paléontologue au muséum d'histoire
naturelle de tucuman en argentine
ça c'est la première fois que nous avons
un invité du du continent sud américain
et donc tu utilises un spécialiste des
dinosaures et des faunes mésozoïque en
général avec une passion très prononcé
pour les spinosaures idée spinosaures
idée d'ailleurs pour lesquelles tu tiens
un site internet le site spinosaures
idée points comme c'est ça qui nous
aurait des points fr pour un génie qui
est tout à fait obsolète
je tiens le signaler dès le départ
depuis quelques années donc voilà la
science est une maîtresse chronophage
mais justement on va on va travailler à
l'update est un peu aujourd'hui tu va
nous raconter des histoires de
spinosaures et donc ton fond d'écran est
tout à fait à propos puisque on va
parler de la queue du spinosaures ça va
être une belle histoire de belles
grosses que aujourd'hui je ne je ne
pouvais pas ne pas la faire voilà moi
les grands spécialistes de la que celles
en fous je la garde
je la garde en montage je m'en fous moi
je suis comme ça moi donc
donc ouais christophe déjà de bon bah je
vais avoir une longue série de questions
pour le coup mais la première de ces
questions ça va peut-être faire un petit
point sur spinosaurus égyptiens accusent
notamment parce que bah c'est un taxon
qu'une longue et tumultueuse histoire
que tu avais déjà résumé
dans notre précédente vidéo sur les
spinosaures idée que je vais mettre
quelque part par là où par là je ne sais
pas trop je serai sur la vidéo mais
voilà je mettrais un petit lien pour
accéder à cette vidéo mais est ce que tu
peux nous refaire un petit historique
des découvertes de spécifiquement de
spinosaurus egypte y accuse parce que
aujourd'hui quand on parle spinosaures
aujourd'hui on parle pas spinosaures
idée on va parler spinosaurus égyptiens
cus oui mais j'ai quand même commencer
par définir l'animal parce que peut-être
que tout le monde n'est pas au bon dans
ce cas un spinosaure dinosaure us c'est
un genre de spinosaures idée un jeune
dinosaure théropode ya vécu dans le nord
de l'afrique
allal bien entre l'albien le cénomanien
il ya entre 170 et 200 millions d'années
et c'est ainsi le spinosaurus des le
plus récent c'est également à présent le
plus complet et le plus dérivés c'est à
dire que c'est le spin autorités qui
montrent toutes une série de deux
caractères dérivés que d'autres
minorités un peu plus basauri plus
anciens ne montre pas alors c'est un
dinosaure tout à fait particulier un
dinosaure théropode qui est comme la
plupart des autres spinosaures idées à
un crédit crocodile forme c'est à dire
avec un museau très allongée vers
l'avant très étroit une marge des dents
des mâchoires inférieure et supérieure
qui édite sigmoïde c'est-à-dire avec
certaines dents qui pointe vers l'avant
les dents elles-mêmes sont spécialisées
elles sont comics et de spinosaures
contrairement à d'autres spinosaures
idée ne porte pas de denticules de ces
rations comme sur la croûte au lait par
exemple les narines du musée sont
rétractés vers l'arrière les dents
montre la dentition montre une très
forte et perdante si c'est à dire avec
les dents antérieures boucle beaucoup
plus grandes que celles postérieures
et puis ça c'est pour le matériel
crânien pour ce qui est du poste crânien
évidemment ce dinosaure est très connu
pour avoir une voile dorsale
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs qu'il a été
nommé sénateur us pink finasser ses
épines donc des épines oral très
allongée et puis on va le voir aussi et
ça s'était montré assez récent
man des membres postérieurs cours et
puis une coeur alors ça c'est la grande
nouvelle une queue qui montre des épines
orale particulièrement longue mais ça on
va y revenir
donc c'est un dinosaure qui mentent
toutes sortes d'adaptations d'abord et
avant tout un régime piscine alors on a
des preuves directes non pas seulement
chez baryonyx ce spinosaures idée qui
vient d'angleterre où on a trouvé dans
son contenu stomacal non seulement des
restes d'un dinosaure juvénile un iguane
au nom du ministre allemand de des cayes
de poissons qui montre d une sorte
d'arbre à lyon fait par des acides mais
elle est également chez spinosaurus le
un très grand muzeau qui a été découvert
il ya une dizaine d'années de cela un
peu plus
il ya des cas une écaille de d'un poids
sont assez fréquents en week-end et puis
doivent-elles si je me trompe qui qui
s'est retrouvée par exemple
coincé dans une des alvéoles donc
manifestement c'est un dinosaure qui se
nourrissait majorité l'ont
majoritairement poissons et alors c'est
un dinosaure qui est connue aussi pour
sa grande taille
on sait maintenant que le crâne de
véronique aurait même les 1 m 75 mètre
75 quand même un crâne le crains
d'ailleurs le plus grand et donc une
taille qui a été estimé à une longueur
entre voilà ça aussi entre 13 m et 2,16
m il semblerait que ce soit le dinosaure
théropode le plus grand amour édité il
est connu donc lolo type a été découvert
en 1912 par mes richard marc graf qui
était l'assistant d'un paléontologue
allemand très connu qui s'appelle ernst
romer qui est en a fait une description
en 1915 il s'agit d'un matériel qui a
été découvert en egypte dans
en cette oasis de bahariya qui qui a
fourni d'autres d'autres dinosaures mais
non que spinosaures est le plus connu
d'entre eux et c'est un donc ce matériel
a permis aux promeneurs donc de définir
spinosaures qui est donc ce matériel
dans le type est malheureusement et
c'est tout c'est pour ça aussi que
spinosaures fascine autant c'est ce
matériel dans le type a été détruit en
1944 lors d'un bombardement des alliés
des anglais en avril 944 sur le musée de
paléontologie de munich
tout le matériel qui a été décrit par
straumur qui est permis de définir
spinosaures a été complètement détruit a
disparu n'a disparu
en revanche son heure on a fait une
description assez détaillé suivant et
les planches sont particulièrement
détaillé il ya un an elles sont en très
bien fait donc quand on a quand même ce
matériel pour nous permettre de faire
des comparaisons avec des matériaux qui
serait découvert plus tard ces dernières
années donc ça c'est pour la petite
histoire par rapport à leur type de
spinosaures donc découvert dans au début
du 20e siècle qui a été détruit lors de
ce raid aérien des anglais en 1944 et
puis d'autres éléments étaient
découverts surtout au maroc
je vous ai parlé de ce museau
gigantesque anna m de long qui a permis
d'estimer le crâne plus d'un mètre
soixante découvert par des collecteurs
dans les calmes keim donc les canes
kembs et une zone du maroc située au sud
est du maroc
on va y revenir aussi parce que c'est là
qu'il a été découvert un squelette
relativement complet par ibrahim et son
équipe
il ya une dizaine d'années et qu'est-ce
que donc il ya eu d'autres osent ils
manquaient
été découvert surtout des éléments très
fragmentaire généralement dont on n'a
pas d'informations précises quant à
l'heure au site à la localisation
puisque il faut savoir que les calmes
kembs son premier fortement par les
locaux qui vendent les fossiles sur le
marché et il ya plusieurs plusieurs
années de cela non mais dans les années
avant les années 2000 et 2010 pas mal de
paléontologues se procurer ce matériel
en les achetant et donc par exemple en
1926 un paléontologue canadien du nom de
russell a décrit des vertèbres et des
éléments crânien comme par exemple une
partie de mâchoires de mandibules qui
qui viennent également des calmes keim
qui ont été achetés et dont on ne
connaît pas la localisation précise la
localité et ça a permis à bruxelles de
définir une nouvelle espèces de
spinosaures spinosaurus maroccan us et
d'après russe il c'est une espèce qui se
différencierait de leur type que
spinosaurus a été quelque chose dans la
proportion des corps vertébraux dans des
centres ou des vertèbres cervicales
donc ça a permis à russell de définir
une nouvelle espèce spinosaurus l'anus à
musso qui étaient découverts en algérie
et qui provient de dépôt albien a permis
à russe était attaqué attaqué ce
paléontologue français célèbre de de
référé ce numéro un spinosaurus maroccan
us pourquoi marocaine n'a pas vraiment
de l'est les auteurs ne le justifie pas
vraiment parce que en fait spinosaurus
avec les pierres que ce n'est pas son
boulot on sait à présent que le museau
appartient probablement fait très froid
et puis voilà il faut évidemment parler
de cette découverte a été faite par
blizzard ibrahim et son équipe dont
va pour le sert et non des
paléontologues italiens comme del sasso
celui qui avait décrit donc ce grand
musée ont fait une découverte alors
c'est pas vraiment de découverte puisque
en fait nizar ibrahim a fait son sa
thèse de doctorat sur les ossements
vertébrés des gammes kane est il là il a
eu contact avec des des marchands et des
collecteurs sur place marocains dont un
qui lui proposait en fait des vertèbres
et des épis de morale très allongé qui
manifestement appartenait des drogues et
nizar a demandé à retrouver ce collector
comme s'il n'avait plus perdu de vue
déjà pour l'anecdote il a demandé à ce
collector de de le mener en fait aux
sites sur le site où ce collector avait
trouvé les ces éléments là et il
s'agissait en fait uniquement de
quelques restes de vertèbres dorsales si
je ne la trompe avec des épis normale et
grâce à cela
nizar a redécouvert le site d'un
spinosaures articulé relativement
complet chose quasi exceptionnel parce
que la plupart des éléments de
dinosaures de théropodes surtout pascal
terreau port sont très fréquents dans la
gamme kent sont isolés on en a pas deux
on a très très peu de reste articulé et
la non seulement il a retrouvé le site
où le petit plat avait trouvé des
éléments mais il a retrouvé donc le
reste du squelette particulier mais je
dire donc avec des éléments qui
appartiennent au même individu
et voilà ça a été une une découverte qui
a été publié dans les années noires en
2004 2014 je crois ouais c'est ça 2014
donc en fait celles découvertes majeures
faites par l'équipe de nizar ibrahim et
publié donc que dans la revue n'était en
2014 révèle en fait une anatomie tout à
fait particulière de spinosaures par
rapport à celle de théropodes proches
comme par exemple mégalo de ruse ou
tyrannosaure qui
relativement éloignée mais dont kiel qui
montrent en fait ce profil d'un
dinosaure bipède avec avec des membres
poster robuste et bien non les
spinosaures montre en fait des membres
postérieurs très court un bassin
particulièrement peu petit et également
lors des des eaux des pieds est
particulièrement allongée et robuste ce
qui a causé en fait
nizar et son équipe a suggéré que ce
dinosaure et dépeint dinosaures
majoritairement aquatique qui devaient
se déplacer surtout dans l'eau nager
dans l'eau se nourrir dans l'eau alors
correa mais j'aimerais ajouter le fait
que le côté semi-aquatique 1 le mode de
vie semi-aquatique des spinosaures idée
avait déjà été suggérée par une équipe
dirigée par le paléontologue français
romain amiot euros main par un romain
lundi on en fait des isotopes d'oxygène
oxygène 18 il vaut des dents les
spinosaures idée qui montent donc un
seul nom mode de vie plutôt semer un peu
pratique à un mode de vie terrestre pour
savait déjà que les spinosaures idée
était fictive ornent des preuves
directes
on savait également que les spinosaures
été soumis à pratiquer en revanche
classée découvert ce qui nous aurait
publié dans l'es14 démontre le perco
spinosaures était non seulement adapté à
un mode de vie aquatique mais également
devait être 4 pers et ça y est tout à
fait particulier parce qu' il n'existe
aucun théropodes quadrupède
à l'heure actuelle parce qu'il faut
savoir que les réseaux sont hétéros
potes sont les descendants des
théropodes actuelle ce n'est seul
dinosaure avoir survécu à la triste et
tertiaires et il ya 65 millions d'années
et donc spina gens semblent être sans
être le seul héros c'est par cette
reconstitution
proposé par ibrahim et son équipe a été
fortement critiquée il y a des
paléontologues des paliers artistes qui
sont interrogés par rapport au fait
qu'il fallait bien d'une reconstitution
qui est basée sur un seul et même
individu et par plusieurs individus qui
pourraient avoir des stades on peut
génétique donc des stades de
développement différents c'est à dire un
juvénile avec un adulte
des paléontologues qui sont interrogés
sur le fait que ces rites il en fait
vraiment d'une seule et même espèce
parce que c'est mon argument si que
celle d'autres payantes aux log comme
sergio scheiber on estime en fait il
existait plus d'une plus d'une espèce de
spinosaures inné de spinosaures idées
dans les quelques m et là on va parler
donc de cet autre espèce jmax de russes
qui a été décrite également en 1996 par
bruxelles bruxelles qui donc décrit des
vertèbres cervicales connectés articulé
et qui voit en fait une un nouveau jean
de théropodes une famille inconnue alors
ses vertèbres ont été re décrite il n'y
a pas très longtemps et qui les
paléontologues ont démontré en fait que
ces pertes elles appartenaient à ce qui
nous aurait menés inspirante spinosaures
idée si j'aime la seor saurait donc qu'à
un spinosaurus d'emera spinosaures idée
qui aurait vécu donc qui seraient
contents par an va spinosaures mais qui
serait une espèce différente un genre
différent à ses bases et en fait sur la
proportion est demandé sur l'anatomie
des vertèbres cervicales qui sont quand
même très différente de dossiers qui ont
été enregistrées par arch tromeur en
1915 et ça par exemple ça a été
complètement rejetée par ibrahim ibrahim
izzat ibrahim estime en fait que tous
les éléments décrits appartenant à des
spinosaures inné du de l'albien et du
cénomanien au nord de l'afrique qui ont
été trouvés dans le nord de l'afrique
parce qu'on n'a pas seulement l'egypte
et le maroc mais on a également
l'algérie la tunisie la libye et même le
dr tout ça ça appartient à la seule et
unique espèces une autorité
donc ça c'est une autre chose aussi
ça c'est notre ère ça c'est d'après
nizar ibrahim
il n'y a pas trois espèces il y en a
qu'une c'est là qu'une seule absolument
alors tu dis trois espèces et est vrai
que moi je me focalise sur deux espèces
pourquoi parce qu'en fait l'espèce
spinosaurus maroccan us et les pas
reconnu par les paléontologues personne
ne reconnaissait la voie parce que dans
les diagnostics la proportion des décors
vertébraux on sait très bien que ça peut
ça peut changer en fait par rapport à la
position des vertèbres au niveau du cou
en fonction de la position on fait un
nom dans le squelette
donc c'est et puis aussi donc le museau
qui a été référé à ce qu'ils nous
aurions marocaine us nous montrons fait
aucune différence vraiment aucune
différence même les les éléments la
mâchoire du dentaire ne manquent
vraiment aucune différence par rapport à
ce qui est connu dans le lot type je
vous ai dit que le y avait pas de musée
on ne connaît pas le la mâchoire
supérieure d'égypte en revanche on
citerait des panthères et donc les
dentaire qui ont été décrits par recel
par exemple qui ont été référées à cette
espèce spinosaurus n'a obtenu aucune
différence il le note lui-même aucune
différence avec le matériel d'égypte
donc cette espèce marocain ne l est pas
et il est rejeté par la majorité des
hommes en revanche si j'ai le massage or
ce site une autre chose si j'aime ma
saison est reconnue en tant que espèces
de spinosaures idées différentes de ce
qui nous aurait s'agit petite couche et
donc c'est basé surtout sur l'anatomie
des vertèbres cervicales d'après evers
en fait il ya trop de différences entre
ses vertèbres cervicales et dorsales et
ses peurs comme ce roman a décrit à
d'équipement dans les années 1915 et
pourquoi on fait donc ça s'est mise à
ibrahim à a publié deux papiers très
important on décemment
un sur les faune et la géologie la
stratigraphie des calmes thème où ils
rejettent le genci il l'a dit lui qui en
fait toutes les différences qui se
trouvent dans les vertèbres cervicales
bien ce sont soit des différents
différences qui peuvent s'expliquer par
une variabilité et s'y fixe mais je me
permets de teintes et rompre rapidement
c'est juste pour dire que donc tu nous a
fait vraiment un historique extrêmement
précis et de cet historique
on sent qu'il ya une chose qui est en
faillite chose qui tend à revenir et
c'est vraiment le fait que comme n'y a
pas de l'eau type comme le lot type
n'est pas préservée en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'on est on est un peu
dans la mouise quand il s'agit
d'attribuer le matériel qu'on trouve
dans les calmes keim
c'est un des problèmes qui a été
soulevée par sergio scheiber ce que il
ya quand même une immense distance entre
les quais mais le gisement égyptien
notre quelque chose comme 3000 ou 4000
kilomètres que ça et du coup ça ça pose
problème pour pour l'attribution du
matériel c'est à dire que quand on parle
de spinosaurus égyptiens cus au final on
n'est même pas sûr qu'on parle du même
spinosaures que celui que ce tromeur a
décrit donc c'est ce qui a l'air de
ressortir en fait de ce débat sur
combien il ya des espèces de spinosaures
idées en afrique du nord c'est le
problème c'est qu'on le matériel de
référence qui était spinosaures qui
était le type de spinosaurus égyptiens
cus étant perdus on est un peu en roue
libre quoi c est ce que je me trompe
non absolument c'est exact c'est tout à
fait vrai mais encore une fois je le
signale et fait que les planches de ce
fromage sont très détaillés sont bien
faites les la description est très bien
faite également donc il est quand même
tout à fait possible de comparer tout
matériel qui ce qui a été trouvé et été
référées spinosaures avec celui qui a
été décrit par par un repreneur en 1915
même si celui là a disparu quand même on
a en est vraiment des données très
précises mais cédric et verse rejette
sonné au type
en effet comme tu le dit très bien parce
que normalement quand tu designo type
c'est 1 1 à nîmes
qui doit se trouvaient généralement dans
les mêmes dépôts et dans dans la même
dans une situation géographique
relativement proche de l'autisme chose
qui est rejetée aussi par par ibrahim
parce que il est dit qu'il serait bien
que bas il ya des espèces actuelles qui
ont une répartition géographique immense
qui sont séparés par des milliers de
kilomètres et qui appartiennent bien là
mais ça ils rejettent sa donc cette
distance il la rejette complètement par
rapport à sa part à la distribution
géographique des espèces actuelles ce
que dit également éleveur c'est que ben
ils posent questions et se demandent si
le néo type est bien basé sur un seul
individu
et puis ils le regardent un peu mais mes
notes il le ski le rêveur et ses
collègues qui le rejette aussi un peu
haut ce qu'il critique c'est que le néo
type est quand même basé sur des
éléments qui ont été d'abord et avant
tout collecter collectées par par des
marchands et qui ont été d'acheter non
pas ce qu'ils disent en fait c'est que
on n'est absolument pas sûr de savoir si
le néo petit pégase et non seulement sur
un seul individu mais surtout aussi sur
des éléments qui appartiennent au même
site et ça encore une fois ça a été tout
à fait rejeter par nizar ibrahim qui
démontre en fait que tous les éléments
appartiennent bel et bien un seul
individu
il critique ça parce que de très bons
arguments il dit qu'en fait les éléments
qui ont été trouvées ne sont pas alors
je décide dans ce trouble ya pas de
duplication des opère raison il ya donc
le néo type juste pour juste pour mettre
au clair le néo type c'est le nouveau
spécimen que ibrahim a décrit en 2014 et
la queue qui vient d'être décrit
appartient aussi aux néo type donc elle
a été collecté auquel a été collectée à
un autre moment que le reste du matériel
mais il ya quand même de bonnes raisons
de croire qu'elle appartient au même
spécimens c'est même certain
déjà c'est lui qui a été trouvé sur le
même site
c'est une continuation des éléments qui
avait été trouvé et qui ont été écrits
en 2014 non non c'est que appartient
sans aucun doute à l'individu au reste
de spinosaures qui ont ils écrit en 2014
donc on l'a en fait
nizar discrédite complètement pour les
arguments des moeurs en disant qu' il
est absolument certain que tous ces
éléments qui définissent le néo type
appartiennent bel et bien seul individu
donc comme je vous ai dit il n'y a pas
de duplication des opère un argument
très important quand même parce que s'il
y avait d'autres individus il serait
tout à fait logique de trouver plusieurs
zones de par exemple d'un tibia d'un
fémur et tout ça on en trouverait 3 plus
tôt
non là c'est certain il n'y a aucune
publication des ces biens se serait
emmerdant mais pour un tibia exactement
pour je sais pas un museau bref les
débats duplication des opèrent les
recouvrements ya pas de recouvrement
norme iso donc on ne peut pas non plus
les mêmes mots les mêmes exacte de ce
site si bien par là donc par exemple si
on devait trouver un des maxillaires
dont on n'a pas trouvé un autre il ya ça
et puis tous les éléments viennent du
couche dont la part dont la
sédimentologie particulier donc oui je
sais pas exactement mais qui auraient
des couleurs particulières
corinne d'écologie ne finissent à une
proposition particulière donc on peut
vraiment voir que tous les éléments
appartiennent bel et bien la même couche
et il ya vraiment très peu de chance on
fait qu'il s'agisse de éléments qui
auraient été trouvées autres par
ailleurs et puis une bizarrerie brahim
c'est tout à fait confiance aux lecteurs
pas du tout l'impression que le
collecteur lui a menti en effet concept
il ya eu aussi des déshérités des
éléments qui a été trouvé par les
collecteurs que s'articulent qui se
joignent très bien avec des éléments qui
pouvaient par ibrahim et sont donc voilà
dix arlette complètement toutes les
accusations d'utilisation les pouces cas
puisque appuyait rêveur et donc il
accepte non seulement gagné un type
évidemment et il rejette aussi là
aisance autre spin off in autorités donc
un coeur donc pour lui son spécimen qui
l'a publiée en 2014 et dont il vient de
publier la queue c'est la nouvelle
référence pour spinosaurus égyptiens cus
et aux passagers il fait d'une pierre
deux coups puisqu'il dit et de toutes
lettres qui a pas d'autres espèces que
spinosaurus égyptiens accusent longueur
exacte finalement il dit c'est que
maintenant vers le néant type est plus
complet que lolo petit et ça c'est quand
même quelque chose d'important il ya
plus d'élément par exemple l'acte
n'était pas connue donc c'est pour ça
que cette nouvelle publication des
vertèbres caudales de l'acut spinosaures
est très importante aussi parce que
l'accueil de spinosaurus est absolument
pas connu et ce qu'elle démontre alors
je sais pas si on peut parler de ça
maintenant
mais elle démontre que la queue était
tout à fait particulière les épines
neural des vertèbres caudales sont très
très allongée et les chevrons donc ces
petits os qui se trouve en fait dans la
partie ventrale de l'accueil qu'ils sont
des hommes l'ont ces petits qui pointe
vers l'arrière sont très longs également
et donc sa librairie mais son équipe
reçue que j'ai en fait que c'est que est
bien très similaire en fait à une queue
de de triton actuelle c'était un moyen
de propulsion langues
donc c'est une nouvel argument pour dire
que le spinosaures était aquatique même
pas semer et gothique aquatique et qu'il
utilise est 7e à des fins de propulsion
[Musique]
comme un crocodile actuelle en fait et
qu'il devait l'aider aussi à se
stabiliser dans l'eau ce qui avait déjà
été proposée d'ailleurs par d'autres
scientifiques comme d'imsa y voit dans
cette voile d'or seul chez spinosaures
une un moyen de se stabiliser dans l'eau
et par exemple
lorsqu'il devait chasser et devait donc
dossier de déplacer son coût très
rapidement pour attraper des proies
et bien c'est un système qui devait
stabiliser l'animal dans l'eau lorsqu'on
voit également par exemple chez les
poissons montre aussi une nageoire
dorsale très allongée donc ça c'est la
découverte qui a été fait tout à fait
récemment une queue qui ne s'apparentent
absolument pas à tous les coups qu'on
connaît les théropodes proches comme
tyrannosaure comme allosaure comme
cératosaure et qui m'ont fait que le
spinosaures et super spécialisé à un
mode de vie aquatique non seulement à un
régime piscivores mais également à un
mode de vie particulièrement aquatique
chose qu'on le retrouve donc fait shiso
qu'un autre canadien
il ya aussi une autre particularité de
ce qu'ils disent dans l'article notre
particularité de cette que c'est qu'elle
est absolument pas rigide c'est à dire
que la plupart des théropodes ont une
queue qui est assez rigidifier la halle
apparemment les articulations entre les
vertèbres les igg apophyses sont
vraiment très courte et du coup ça fait
une désarticulation très lâche donc là
que devaient être beaucoup plus mobile
que chez un terreau pod standard c'est
exact
et d'ailleurs en fait ils ont quand il
fit aussi de quantifier le potentiel de
propulsion de spinosaurus comparées à
celles d'autres théropodes sur base de
l'anatomie de la surface de là qu elle
même et ce qui montre en fait c'est que
nizar montre en fait que la poussée la
queue est 1000 fois supérieure à celle
d'autres théropodes en moyenne en
revanche celle du crocodile est
supérieure à celle de spinosaures en
supérieur 1.5 celle de la des poussées
de spinoza et donc oui voilà c'est une
queue qui qui montre tout ça sorte
d'adaptation à un mode de vie aquatique
donc c'était alors que spinosaurus a été
vu comme un
exactement comme un dinosaure terrestre
qui se nourrissait de poisson le long
des berges des rivières la mise à lire
en italie brahim le propose justement vu
que tu parles de ce graphe du coup c'est
ce fameux graf
donc ils ont utilisé un modèle une
reconstitution de la queue en en pvc de
spinosaurus et donc ils l'ont testé pas
en soufflerie mais en gros c'est comme
une soufflerie mais avec de l'eau quoi
et déjà déjà on reconnaît le style
national geographic pour faire de la
science
je trouve ces c'est plus c'est plus
visuel qu'autre chose on va dire oui
mais c'est parce que les gens arrivent à
comprendre
voilà moi - mathématiques que d'autres
publications ça c'est très bien on va la
constitution de leur sort et de ses le
physique on voit très bien que c'est que
est déjà très longue et très fine et
donc très très étroite entre
d'entraînement alors que celle de
spinosaures avec ses traits avec ses
épines neural très allongée dans ses
cheveux blonds très en vue également et
règles en a une que similaire c'était le
des triptans actuelle et les
crocodiliens d'accord donc ce qu'on voit
sur le graphe la trust
ce trust c'est la traînée du coup et
évasion si c'est là l'efficacité le
j'imagine la propulsion et donc donc
évidemment plus on a de plus on a de
traîner propulsion est meilleur on est à
nager et come on come il ne quantifie
pour l'instant que la queue du coup une
meilleure on est pour nager avec
l'accueil donc déjà basket bien dans ton
historique c'est que déjà on voit que
c'est pas spécialement nouveau cette
histoire de
de deux semi aquatique en fait ce nouvel
article
il ne démontre pas le mode de vie
aquatique de spinosaures il enfonce le
clou quoi mais c'est le cloud qui était
déjà bien enfoncée oui c'était mais bon
on ne s'attend donc non pas avoir
personne ne s'attendait à avoir en fait
des adaptations si d'un dinosaure c'est
quand même incroyable de l'espinouse
aurait dit sont très spécialisés dans ce
régime qui six morts dont toutes sortes
d'adaptations qu'on ne voit pas fait
d'autres encore qui nous aurait eu
c'était vraiment des nez un niveau
supérieur une queue très très très
bizarre qu'on le retrouve chez aucun
théropodes fois des membres
un postérieur très court une vol dorsale
excessivement longue
aussi on ne voit pas chez d'autres
dinosaures théropodes mais en effet le
mode de vie semi-aquatique ça c'est on
le sait déjà depuis une dizaine d'années
grâce à ce pagne et au rock français en
aragon
en revanche j'aimerais quand même le
spécifier ça c'est assez particulier
dans son papier sur sur donc le côté les
isotopes qui démontre le côté sommier
kotick le signal semi aquatique des
spinosaures idée eh bien il ya des dents
de spinosaurus qui viennent des kenkel
part de spinosaures idée de spinosaurus
d'après venise à qui montrent un signal
plutôt terrestre et ça c'est quand même
particulier
et justement ça me conforterait dans
cette idée que peut-être il y aurait en
effet deux espèces de genre de
spinosaures idées dans les quelques m1
qui pourrait être tout à fait adapté un
mode de vie aquatique qui devait vivre
majoritairement dans l'eau est peut-être
une autre
si j'ai une base aux russes peut-être
alors ce sont des hypothèses
je ne le confirme au cumin ce retrait
est une espèce beaucoup plus terrestre
qui elle pourrait pêcher par exemple sur
les bords de dérive de rivière ça
pourrait expliquer en fait 7 sur le
résultat qui a été obtenu par par un
myope pour certaines
en de spinosaurus alors qu'au contraire
les dents dessus comme hymus et de barry
ionix les spinosaures idées qui sont
connus dans le nord de l'afrique et en
europe montre vraiment un signal de d'un
mode de vie tout à fait semi aquatique
donc voilà ça c'est pour ajouter des
informations par rapport à ce côté
semi-aquatique aquatique ou peut-être
terré sur de certains ne certain jean du
pin autorité j'aimerais bien revenir sur
le sur le graphe parce qu'il ya un truc
qui me chiffonne un peu danse graff et
le groupe compte un groupe contrôle le
contrôle est vachement semi aquatique
oui et le contrôle apparemment c'est un
modèle alors la seule chose qu'ils
disent à propos du groupe contrôle c'est
que c'est un cube et à un recteur en
fait c'est un rectangle ce pas justement
parce qu'en fait c'est un rectangle qui
dans les proportions
c'est pas vraiment mais je sais pas moi
ça me de saint-andré à ça tendrait à
indiquer qu en gros le le le modèle
qu'ils ont utilisé la façon qu'ils ont
utilisés pour tester justement le la les
capacités comment dire l'efficacité de
la nage de spinosaurus en grosse part
dans le potentiel de propulsion oui le
potentiel de propulsion de spinosaurus
en gros ça leur méthode tendrait à aller
aller à envoyer n'importe quel modèle
plutôt du côté semi-aquatique que du
côté terrestre en fait et c'est pareil
pour l'efficacité ici le contrôle il est
pareil il est équivalent au crocodile et
là il est
et il est équivalent au spinosaurus de
ce côté là donc c'est moi j'aurais bien
aimé j'aurais bien aimé voir en fait ce
serait plutôt un jour à nos eaux russes
ou un autre truc avec une crête dont on
est à peu près sûr que là que n'était
pas flexible non je ne sais pas si les
épines neural de l'accueil
particulièrement il est allongé en
revanche les écoles et c'est bien que tu
parles de ça parce que on peut aussi
dire qu'il y avait d'autres dinosaures
pas des théropodes mais d'autres
dinosaures qui montrent une sorte de
voile au niveau de la queue comme si je
ne me trompe pas si je ne me trompe
aussi rock toxicité des sites et
causeries je crois que ces protocoles ou
alors on fait des cératopsidés base on
me rappelait en fait y en a une qui
montre vraiment une sorte de deux vols
encore une fois au niveau là que hé ça
on sait très bien que c'était des
dinosaures terrestres
donc ce n'est pas la seule à montrer ça
mais bon là là ça aurait été intéressant
d avoir en danse graff parce que du coup
ça ça aurait un peu rajouté de l'eau à
leur moulin là le problème c'est que du
coup ça donne une petite impression de
pas finie qua non c'est pas possible je
suis pas du tout je t'avouerai que je
suis pas très spécialisés sa part ça m'a
pas choqué le contrôle peut-être que
sont expliqués dans le futur mais en
tout cas moi j'aimerais quand même dire
que pour le moment autant la
reconstitution du squelette en 2014 a
vraiment a été très controversé beaucoup
beaucoup de blogs ont critiqué cette
autant là j'ai envie de dire quand même
que la plupart des landes
on est d'accord avec cette idée de sept
copains personne ne peut racheter le
fait que c'est que la vie cette forme
alors voit très bien que les épines
neural des vertèbres caudales sont
rallongés en fait ce set que aussi
démontre le fait qu' ils étaient fortes
chances que les les membres postérieurs
comme le fémur comme les tibias qui sont
particulièrement de faux et bien c'est
pas c'est pas une anomalie quoi c'est
vraiment une caractéristique de
spinosaures spinosaurus montrent
vraiment d adaptation à un mode de vie
aquatique très très poussée donc voilà
ça
supportant pas l'idée de nizar rayan en
ouais non j'ai peut-être tendance à être
un peu trop critique à propos de cet
article c'est parce que dès la deuxième
page en gros il ya un truc qui m'a pas
plu la deuxième page bordel déjà ils
surent vend beaucoup le fait qu' on n'a
jamais découvert un truc semi aquatique
à vendre sachant que sachant que c'est
pas enfin je veux dire il sait il
exagère un petit peu je trouve ce côté
là le côté semi-aquatique puisque déjà
il l'avait démontré enfin il avait déjà
bien d'enfoncer le clou en en 2014 mais
bon il ya aussi il ya d'autres espèces
de dinosaures semi aquatique au crétacé
comme liaoning aux russes qui est un
genre de je crois c'est un an qu'ils
osent or c'est un an kilos d'or de 2,2
chine qui a été qui ressemble vachement
une tortue qui est tout petit qui a à
peine aussi fier et qui a des du poisson
dans l'estomac
donc là on a quand même une bonne une
bonne série de preuves aussi pour
liaoning aux russes puis après ça bon
bref voilà il ya espère ornis aussi mais
là qui en aura bien pour le coup et qui
est vraiment de la fin du crétacé donc
pas pas aussi pas aussi vieux que
spinosaurus lui-même mais il ya surtout
un truc et oui peut-être que tu vas
parler de ça il ya surtout elle ce cas
là asca me asca raptor web alors asca
raptor c'est encore très débattue est ce
que ca vrai ou est ce que c'est un faux
nom ça c'est un vrai il ya peu de doute
franchement est ce que c'est vrai qu'il
y avait le scan synchrotron du spécimen
ils n'ont pas réussi à démontrer que
c'était un faux et ils ont même trouvé
une espèce de fissures qui va qui
traverse tout le spécimen et qui
traverse beaucoup d'os dans le spécimen
donc apparemment
enfin si si c'était des faussaires et
ils ont ils quitté ce que disait paul
tafforeau c'est que si ces défauts serre
ils ont ils ont pensé à faire une
fissure qui cassent tous les hauts de la
même façon dans tous les sens qu en gros
même et c'est vrai que enfin l'aspect du
truc est quand même hyper suspect mais
bon oui mais bon je serais pas surpris
je serais pas surpris que dans un futur
proche finalement reviennent deux sur
dix arbres n ont peut-être pas en fait
moi justement pas il faut il faut
arrêter de critiquer
des records de faim des dinosaures pour
leurs bizarreries parce qu'on se rend
compte de l'évolution de mener à des des
animaux qui ont des adaptations très
particulière avec des déclins je crois
donc il faut vraiment pas critiquer la
bizarrerie de serre de certains animaux
et là en tout cas pour aspirer raptor ce
que je veux dire c'est que la wii comme
tu le dis toi même le site is khan le
démontre amplement qui s'alignent poney
4 et n'ont pas trouvé de paul et tous
les aliments s'articule correctement il
peut voir franchement que je serai
devient bien d'eux parce qu'il est
entouré de matrice de sédiments tout
décidément à porter ou bien ils sont
similaires
l'ipo logique on vraiment pas ainsi
franchement à ce caractère est
certainement à l animal qui n'a pas été
il n'a pas qu'il n'a pas été reconstruit
par des vendeurs encore une fois c'est
tout le problème aussi c'est que ce
dinosaure a été acheté sur le marché
hier sur le site malheureusement c'est
ça le problème c'est que spinosaurus
égyptiens qc alsc à raptor ils ont en
commun d'avoir justement cette
bizarrerie morphologie morphologique
c'est à dire les proportions bizarres
des membres postérieurs de spinosaurus
ses pires cas raptor c'est tout c'est
tout le corps qui est qui est bizarre
ils ont aussi en commun d'avoir été
achetés sur le marché noir quoi donc
sonné mais on est quand même on est
quand même en droit il est quand même en
droit de se poser des questions il nous
en reste plus maintenant
par contre il faut franchement donné le
créa en isère ibrahim tout ce qu'il a
publiés et c'est lui qui l'a trouvée sur
le site un site d'assurance i télé qu'il
a escalé pendant plusieurs années avec
une équipe
alka raptor ça c'est tout à fait
différent ça c'est un seul spécimen qui
a été vendue par françois d'ailleurs si
je ne me trompe ce jour france oui oui
mais en tout cas moi le site is khan n'a
pas démontré le peu de terreau constitué
de l'animal donc tout porte à croire que
c'est un fait les mêmes individus
le squelette respiratoires et donc oui
je sais pas en fait
ou est-ce que tu as lu comme
nous on serait l'unique théropodes sont
mis à terre pendant la vie en somme il
est pratique mais en tout cas c'est vrai
qu'on n'en peut mais que d'autres comme
mascarade store qui montrent une série
d'adaptations là c'est plutôt au niveau
des des membres postérieurs et enterré
antérieure à venir c'est plutôt il
aurait des nageoires au niveau des seins
puis un coup très allongée par ns a été
reconstituée comme une sorte de signe du
credes est en fait un scanner donc des
diffuseurs semi-aquatique que beyond
connaissez les gens savaient très bien
qu est ce qui nous aurait dit semi
aquatique en revanche une que de cette
façon on ne connaissait pas et donc oui
tout à fait particulier très intéressant
ouais bah c'est le là où j'avais entendu
enfin c'est le côté il a été vendu par
national geographic comme le premier
dinosaure théropode semi-aquatique donc
voilà pour l'institut de répertoire
assira à l'article lui même de nature tu
peux lire beaucoup beaucoup de trucs qui
sont incorrectes ouais mais j'aime bien
critiquer la façon dont les découvertes
sur voire du ca à oui ça ramènerait vues
sur youtube
justement d'aider un journée hyper
sérieux en où ils recoupent quand même
lors de données et donc oui en effet je
n'en sais vraiment pas le seul
théropodes semi-aquatique alors par
contre ce qu'on sait toujours pas ce que
est ce que et les autres spin o d'ohrid
y avait autant d'adapter de l'adaptation
l'accueil en tout cas de de cette espèce
du laos ic tir venator décrit par ronan
allain paléontologue français ne montre
pas des épines neural aussi allongé
niveau des clubs donc baryonyx et
baryonyx je ne sais plus je ne suis pas
vérifié je ne crois pas que ce sais pas
si on n'en déversé cours d'abb avec le
brt les épines orale si allongerait mais
je ne crois pas ok on sait très bien que
la voile d'orsay n'était pas aussi il y
avait une voile dorsale mais beaucoup
plus courtes donc des hippies neural
relativement allongé au niveau des
vertèbres dorsales
en revanche pour les vertèbres caudales
j'en sais rien vérifier rapidement mais
je crois vraiment un truc qu'on trouve
uniquement chez les dinosaures
d'accord pendant ce temps là je vais
montrer aux quais bas donc ces voix là
là c'est en rouge c'est les morceaux
qu'ils ont trouvé en 2014 en jaune c'est
les morceaux qu'ils ont trouvé en jeu
ses plus grands et en bleu c'est la
nouvelle que qui viennent de décrire
q donc ce qu'on voit c'est quand même
ils ont surtout les partie postérieure
donc ça mais ça met un peu de l'eau au
moulin aux gens qui veulent dire que en
gros les les proportions des membres
postérieurs par rapport aux membres
antérieurs
elle pourrait être relativement fausses
donc j'aime posture cette fameuse
posture quadrupède
elle serait peut-être fassi si on part
du principe que les membres antérieurs
n'ont pas été retrouvés en connexion
avec le reste donc leur reconstruction
du squelette à l'est pas forcément juste
enfin je sais pas qu'est ce que tu en
penses
oui non comme tu lui dis les le soleil
qui a été trouvé par l'équipe denis
d'aribert heim esclaves et ne compte pas
de membres antérieurs ou juste des
éléments des phalanges s'apprécier de
constitution qui montre donc là pour le
moment on n'a pas d'information à
l'anatomie des membres antérieurs en
revanche que démontre ce cette
reconstitution c'est que vous avez quand
même ils ont trouvé quand même les
vertèbres dorsales et les vertèbres
dorsales son corps et âme très grande
comparée à par exemple le haut bas ça
ils ont trouvé également au moins une
vertèbre cervicale et puis s'ils disent
en fait que tout ça c'est un seul et
même individu
il faut vraiment les croire ça demande
quand même cet article ce nouvel article
du monde vraiment le ses particularités
des membres postérieurs très court il
faut plus remettre ça en question je
crois donc en revanche c'est vrai qu'on
n'a pas de d'information comme des sa
bande s est basée sur ce qu'on connaît
des autres spin autorisé ça s'appelle de
l'anatomie comparée tu normal d'utiliser
des éléments
d'autres d'autres autorités proches pour
baryonique si vous ne semblez bien donc
on n'a pas du tout les que non plus on a
uniquement en fait les la première les
deux premières vertèbres caudales et
dont les épines aura ne montre aucune
inondation partie du coup j'ai pas j'ai
pas dit tout à l'heure le truc qui
m'avait fait me sentir sceptique par
rapport à l'article on est passé sur
autre chose
le truc qui mène le truc qui en fait
fait que je suis assez sceptique par
rapport à cet article c'est donc dans la
page 2 il
il annonce en fait dès la page 2 que
c'est le plus complet des squelettes du
crétacé de théropodes du crétacé
trouvait en afrique
alors en fait tu dois probablement pensé
à nous préparer sans doute alors ouais
voilà les bases aux russes ou là pour le
coup on connaît tous sauf la queue donc
j'ai presque linverse de spinosaures
est-ce qu'ils ont pas est ce qu'ils
disent
le nord de l'afrique je l'écris à
regarder dans ces mails le most ce
qu'ils disent exactement c'est de most
complète skelton avec ritchie théropodes
notes from my land africa donc le don
qu'ils excluent madagascar en fait parce
qu'à madagascar ils ont des très beaux
fossiles aussi les mêmes bases aux
russes qui est cas de la paix ouais une
poupée base russe qui vient d'afrique du
sud il est plus complet il manque que la
queue pour le coup exactement et lui
c'est père ya dix ans et qu'ils sont ils
donc du coup ça m'a un peu en tant que
paléontologues sud africain ça m'a un
peu hérisser les poils sur la tête et du
cou à partir de cette phrase là j'ai été
très sceptique du contenu de l'article
donc peut-être trop je vois que tu ne
partage pas mon scepticisme pour tous
les aspects n'ont pas hésité alors le
point quand même le plus important c'est
l'anatomie de la queue qui peut pas être
guillet
c'est quelque chose qu'ils ont trouvé et
puis quand même
leur hypothèse comme moi c'était une
queue qui était devait être utilisé
comme moyen de propulsion morlot ces
personnes comment lire un sous-pull
terre bref passant convaincant c'est ce
que je voulais dire ça semble très
convaincant maintenant aux rives
en effet ils sont trompés par rapport
aux tirs au but le plus complet de du
crétacé l'afrique
ils ont oublié une cow boys drôle
parfois ok alors et il ya aussi un truc
que je voulais te demander c'est on a
découvert il ya pas longtemps enfin il
ya on a découvert le nouveau spécimen de
tyrannosaure qui vient d'être publié rsm
p25 23.8 mali est apparemment un nouveau
à nouveau gros tyrannosaurus rex plus
gros que sioux
alors du coup on va en revenir à cette
bonne vieille question de qui c'est qui
gagnent entre entre tyrannosaurus et
spinosaurus c'est est ce que ça fait
toujours de spinosaurus le plus gros des
théropodes ou pas voyez si on part donc
il faut spécifier si on part de la
longueur très probablement si on parle
de la robustesse non ce nouveau spécimen
de tyrannosaure il n'a pas été proposé
comme le plus grand mais comme le plus
robuste
parce qu'en fait c'est basé sur le
diamètre la circonférence de du fémur
qui est le plus grand parmi tous les
tyrannosaures dont fou soul pourrait
être plus grand dans sa longueur sousse
et entre 11 et 12 m quelque chose comme
ça ce tyrannosaure ce nouveau spécimen
je sais pas quelle taille est estimée en
revanche il serait plus robuste et donc
plus lourd cinq cibles qu'il prône dans
leur art
en revanche pour spinosaurus c'est
toujours débattue ont fait on revient
toujours au même à la même chose
maintenant on commence à voir de plus en
plus d'informations quant à la longueur
de la queue par exemple longueur du
crâne mais tout ça ça repose toujours
sur des reste relativement fragmentaire
des estimations des estimations c'est
toujours pour le moment pour ceux qui ne
dort entre 12 13 mètres jusqu'à 16 16
mètres ça a été proposée par dal sasso
sur base de crosse au crâne
ça a été constaté et pin kung
achetons plus tard maintenant ça a été
rejetée par terry anderson qui disent
que le spinosaures devrait plutôt
roaring taille de 2 13 mètres donc 13
mètres ces détails qu'on retrouve chez
empêcher tyrannosaure j'ai plutôt chez
les giganotosaurus et
carcharodontosaures rue il nous faut
tout simplement pour répondre à cette
question des squelettes encore plus
complet de spinosaurus ce conte ce
squelette qui a été décrit par nizar
ibrahim relativement complet s'est il
semblerait que ce ne soit pas un animal
adultes c'est plutôt un subadulte bien
que c'est pour être encore un énième
elle qui a pu grandir encore celui là si
je ne me trompe
si je ne me trompe il a été estimé à a
dit m mais cette époque là on ne
connaissait pas l'anatomie de la queue
maintenant on commence à la connaître
je ne sais pas s'il est plus longue plus
court j'ai l'impression il me semble en
fait qu elle est un petit peu plus
courte que les queues qui complète qu'on
connaît pour les ors et si le physique
tout ça est ce que ça réduit et
fortement la taille de spinosaures n'en
sais rien ce qu'on peut dire à l'heure
actuelle c'est que spinosaures est un
des théropodes les plus grands à avoir
vécu et donc il y a peut-être d'autres
dinosaures carnivores comme
giganotosaurus carcharodontosaures us et
peut-être aussi des russes qui ont été
plus lents ski et puisqu'il faut te
prendre en compte avec les estimations
de body mass enfin de poids corporel
c'est que c'est fait c'est fait à partir
de
de d'extrapolation fait sur la
circonférence du fémur généralement
généralement du fémur sinon du tibia et
le fêtait le fait est que ces faits à
partir d' extrapolations d'animaux
terrestres mais si spinosaures passe du
côté semi aquatique de la force les les
estimations de taille de poids du corps
sont sont plus du tout les mêmes puisque
les animaux semi aquatiques sont
beaucoup plus lourds que leurs
équivalents terrestre pensez aux
hippopotames les hippopotames ils sont
vachement plus gros que les que les des
animaux qui auraient la même corpulence
le même squelette mettait mais qui
serait 100% l'aller reste donc tout ça
parce qu'il ya la poussée d'archimède
qui leur permet de soutenir leur poids
c'est bien pour ça que les baleines sont
si grandes c'est parce que comme on n'a
pas à soutenir son poids sous l'eau on
peut se permettre toutes les fantaisies
possible le jour on trouvera un
squelette relativement complet on pourra
dire voilà sur base de ce squelette
on a une taille de 10 mètres et on sait
qu'il ya un crâne nu dans qui encore
plus grand donc on peut estimer
donc pour répondre à la question
finalement qui gagnent entre le
tyrannosaure et le spinosaures bombe a
en tout cas à la brasse coulée
c'est spinosaures je pense qu'il ya
d'intéressant avec cette publication est
qu'ils n'ont pas vraiment ils n'ont pas
vraiment insister dessus c'est que comme
tu le disais au début trouvé des restes
articulé dans les calmes kembs est
extrêmement rare réclame la trouver
cette que complètement en articulation
c'est la démonstration que même dans les
calmes keim on peut trouver des idées
des spécimens articulé et sachant la
richesse fossiles des calmes comme ça ça
ouvre des portes à ses formidables
exactement tout à fait quand même
rappeler le fait que maintenant ce
dinosaure et le tir open le plus complet
des calcaires dans lesquels il faut le
rappeler c'est une diversité de
théropodes énorme puisqu'on style et on
est légalement carcharodontosaures on
sait qu'on a été
la vidéo rider on les avait dominés par
exemple c'est uniquement connu par deux
restent très fragmentaire crânien était
verte et rossi donc si on pouvait
trouver également un squelette articulé
de cacao manteau rue d'abily leurs idées
on pense maintenant qu'on a des noises
au rider dans lesquelles mme kehm n'a
peut-être désormais autorisée mais ça
c'est vraiment pas certain parce que
c'est passé sur des aidants on a
d'autres héros potes qui sont très très
très fragmentaire carcharodontosaures et
ce serait magnifique qu'on puisse
trouver également à un squelette
articulé il ya beaucoup de choses encore
à trouver
je crois d'ailleurs que nizar ibrahim
bahit retourné 1
maintenant qu'il a un poste permanent de
professeurs je le trouve plus le nom de
la ville mais bref pas important il ya
de fortes chances d'avec un défi
national geographic
il pourra retourner dans lesquels km et
pourra trouver notre truc est telle que
sa prochaine publication ce sera un
squelette articulé de
carcharodontosaures risque et ça aussi
ça va ça va faire la une des journaux un
autre animal qui est fascinant et dont
on connaît vraiment très peu de choses
yes était encore très ouvert est ce
qu'il y avait deux espèces de
spinosaures idées dans les calmes kane
aux normes et l'afrique c'est est ce que
le néo type de spinosaurus correspond
bien
egypte on connaît toujours pas les
membres antérieurs donc il serait
vraiment pas étonnant de voir une autre
publication de nizar ibrahim nourriture
par rapport à l'anatomie des membres
antérieurs qui montrait encore toutes
sortes d'adaptations à un mode de vie
aquatique et encore beaucoup de choses à
trouver par rapport à mai en tout cas
moi ce que je peux dire aussi c'est que
en préparant seule cette interview je
constate qu'on y est de vraiment de plus
en plus de publications sur ce dîner
seront donc ce dinosaure devient un peu
l'équivalent du tyrannosaure où tout le
monde essaie de travailler là dessus
dès qu'il ya quelques uns qui sont
trouvés une publication qui sort il ya
d'autres choses à qui on est et puis y
est justement sur la voile dorsale de
spinosaures à d'autres éléments crânien
qui montre un adepte d'une adaptation un
régime puis simao réussi à un mode de
vie aquatique et de toutes sortes de
choses encore qui qui ont été publiés
récemment et qui monte en faire et que
ce qui nous aurait très très particulier
fascinant et oui on espère voir d'autres
d'autres découvertes dans le futur et
puis on espère voir tes sites ton site
internet et ta page wikipédia update et
je vais tuer une référence il va falloir
mais justement j'invite la sage invitent
les auditeurs tous ceux qui sont
passionnés par il nous aurait désormais
actualisés site internet parce que moi
je suis dans une phase où il me faut
publier pour trouver un site pour
trouver un poste permanent payante parce
que voilà julien lui a trouvé un poste
permanent est génial en plus ils
pourraient être permettre de passer un
peu de tension site internet moi il faut
que je publie et là je ne travaille pas
vraiment sur les spinosaures idées pour
le moment je travaille en fait sur la
peau des aides des théropodes des
dinosaures ce qui est très intéressant
si sur la peau écailleuse et donc tenons
là je vraiment mon énergie je mets toute
mon énergie dans des publications et qui
pourrait me permettre de trouver un
poste fixe de palier entre le futur donc
s'il ya des gens qui sont intéressés qui
actualise le l'article wikipédia puisque
c'est un article j'avais écrit pour
avoir le label articles de qualité qui
est maintenant à l'article de qualité or
il est obsolète
donc voilà chose à faire mais mais je
t'invite et julia à me recontacter
peut-être de futures découvertes
normalement il va y avoir obligation qui
va sortir
bonjour moi qui révèle une information
la diversité morphologique cela est en
pole automatiquement parler nous auriez
il ya des choses hyper intéressante et
le nom ben c'est tout le mal qu'on leur
souhaite
sur ces sur ces bonnes paroles var on te
souhaite on te souhaite de publier cet
article sur la peau des dinosaures et
puis bah du coup je pense qu'on peut se
dire à très bientôt pour une interview
sur l'évolution des écailles et des
plumes
je suppose parce qu'il y aura les plumes
aussi dans le lot l'évolution donc voilà
teaser teaser pour la prochaine
interview de deux du docteur hendrix sur
entracte science la prochaine fois on
parle de l'évolution des plumes avec
grand plaisir plaisir de pouvoir inviter
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
les pays-bas du coup on se dit à très
bientôt d'abord pas de souci
à bientôt et à très bientôt sur notre
chaîne
au revoir
[Musique]